a day in the life for all geladas begins
on the edges of the cliff in the morning
they wake up with the sunrise and slowly
ascend kind of to the edge of the high
plateau they'll spend an hour or maybe
more they're socializing with each other
grooming fun times napping and then the
juveniles go off in flight once the kind
of social periods and morning is
finished they begin a daily ranging
pattern where they'll walk inland as a
big group eating grass and herbs you
want to spend a lot of their time when
they're not feeding building social
relationships with each other and what
that means that they spend a lot of time
grooming one another particularly in
different pairs and then as the day
proceeds they look back around at night
geladas are vulnerable to predation and
so to avoid potential for hyenas or even
leopards to act themselves spend their
nights sleeping perched on cliffs that
overhang the greatest Valley and by dusk
they're grooming and then socializing a
little bit before they go over the edge
of the cliff for tonight's issues
[Music]
you
[Music]